[Applause]
and welcome to book tv on c-span 2's
live coverage of the 28th annual
southern festival of books in downtown
nashville tennessee we're live both
today and tomorrow with several author
events you can find the full schedule at
booktv.org
and you can follow us on social media at
book tv is our twitter handle and
facebook.com book tv to get behind the
scenes videos and pictures as well as
schedule updates now we're going to kick
off the festival with author beth macy
she tells the story of george and willie
muse
they were two african-american brothers
who were kidnapped and forced to perform
in a circus in 1899
and it's about their mother as well who
searched for them for over 28 years this
is live coverage of the southern book
festival on book tv
good morning i'm alice carey as a
reviewer for book page i read a lot of
books and one of my favorites this year
is truvine it took beth macy 25 years to
unearth this saga requiring painstaking
research on multiple fronts to unearth
as she writes to untangle a century of
whispers from truth
the result is deeply moving and
endlessly compelling and such an
intricate tale that is worthy of not one
but two subtitles
two brothers a kidnapping and a mother's
quest and also a true story of the jim
crow south truvine has been shortlisted
for the kirkus prize and long listed for
the andrew carnegie medals for
excellence
as a reporter for the roanoke times in
virginia beth won more than a dozen
awards and earned a neiman fellowship at
harvard university her first book new
york times bestseller factory man was on
numerous best of 2014 lists and is
currently in development to become an
hbo mini-series executive produced by
tom hanks and gary getzman please join
me in welcoming beth macy to the
southern festival of books thank you
alex i appreciate being here
well truvine has all the elements of a
southern gothic novel but it's true so
could you read a section that explains
how you first heard about this story i'd
love to
as a young journalist who'd arrived in
roanoke in 1989 to write feature stories
for the roanoke times i took two years
to muster the nerve to mess with nancy
and she was the story's gatekeeper the
great niece of george and william muse
a newspaper photographer had told me the
bones of the kidnapping story based on
rumors he'd heard growing up in roanoke
quote it's the best story in town but no
one's been able to get it he said
by the time i poked my head into her
tiny soul food restaurant with the idea
of writing a story about her famous
great uncles it was very clear that all
personal details were going to be
closely held trickling out in dribs and
drabs and very much on nancy's timeline
the first time i asked if i could
interview willie muse he was then in his
90s she pointed to a homemade sign on
the goodie shop wall a customer had
stenciled the words in black box letters
on a white painted board and given it to
her as a gift the sign said sit down and
shut up
willie was not now nor would he ever be
available for comment so hoping to
generate some goodwill for a future
story on her uncles i wrote a feature
about her restaurant a place where the
menu never changes and isn't even
written down you're just supposed to
know
legions of black roanokers could already
recite the daily specials i would
eventually commit to memory tuesday is
spaghetti or lasagna except every other
tuesday which is pork chops wednesday is
fish and thursday country fried steak
friday is ribs but you'd better come
early because the ribs always sell out
quickly
the line out front starts forming at
noon though lunch doesn't officially
begin until 12 15 and not a moment
before and later usually if nancy has to
run home to check on uncle willie and
finds him in the midst of a bad day
uncle willie's favorite special was
tuesday spaghetti
nancy also kept a painted rock on top of
her cash register it was a gift from her
preschooler nephew jason whom she helped
raise she was not above picking it up
presumably in jest should a customer
offend her
when i returned for lunch two days after
my story ran because rib fridays were my
favorite nancy shook her finger at me
and it was clear i was not getting
anything close to a pat on the back
dad dot her mother dot set nearby
peeling potatoes watching the young and
the restless and cringing about what her
daughter was about to say
nancy had been ready to send me packing
the first time i walked in the
restaurant and blindly inquired about
her uncles but soft dotted hearted dot
persuaded her to let me stay and do the
restaurant feature
a ynr fan in my youth i actually saw the
very first episode of young and the
restless i'd bonded quickly with dot
over the characters and was helping peel
potatoes in her kitchen before the
episode was over much to nancy chagrin
dot and i both agreed that victor newman
was a scoundrel
you know what your story did nancy said
it brought out a bunch of crazy white
people that's all
paying customers i might have added but
she was in no mood for back talk she
walked past me without further comment
she was leaving now to feed uncle willy
and turn him in his bed as she often did
throughout the day leaving the goodie
shop as many as five or six times a
shift
if nancy saunders had her way her great
uncle story would have stayed buried
where she thought it belonged the first
time she heard it she was just a child
and she found the whole tale
embarrassing and painfully raw
the year was 1961 and black and white
people alike wanted to know were the
light skinned brothers black or white
had they really been trapped in a cage
and forced to eat raw meat
these men deserve respect nancy knew
they did not deserve the gawkers who
came by their house at all hours banging
on the front door that was some of her
first memories of people banging on
their door in the middle of the night
by the time i came on the scene no one
talked about savages or circus freaks in
front of nancy a sturdy woman with a
no-frills afro growing at the temples
whose skin was nearly white as the
chef's coat she wore to work she baked
bread every bit as good as her
great-grandmother harriet's ash cakes
and she was every bit as fierce even red
sharif who knew the family well and he
grew grew up in the neighborhood around
the corner from the muses and is now a
social sciences professor he had never
contemplated bringing the subject up
with them that is one exceptionally
guarded family he told me you got to
take baby steps
you have to think of them as a tribe
they fall out with each other sometimes
but if you fall out with one of them
they will come roaring back at you like
an army
it was 10 more years before nancy warmed
up enough to let me and a co-writer
author a newspaper series about her
uncles and only after willie muse's
death in 2001 he was 108.
she didn't real reveal much though she
invited my fellow reporter jenn
mccaffrey photographer josh meltzer and
me inside the bru muse brothers house
exactly one time
she made reference to a family bible
that we were not permitted to view and
for years after the series ran whenever
i visited the restaurant she hinted that
there was so much more to this story
than we had found she actually would
when she would say things like that she
would call me scoop
our newspaper was the same one that had
mocked her family's version of the
kidnapping story decades earlier it had
looked the other way when city officials
decimated two historic black
neighborhoods in the name of mid-century
progress via urban renewal or as the
black community called it negro removal
the newspaper cheered when the city
knocked down hundreds of community homes
and buildings including the muse
family's holiness church it refused to
print black wedding announcements for
brides until the mid-1970s because the
wealthy white publisher reasoned roanoke
had no black middle class
i myself had used a pair of pregnant
black teens to illustrate a story about
roanoke's super high teen pregnancy rate
in 1993
a story that went viral before that
internet term existed and made the girls
the object of ridicule even rush
limbaugh joined in with a rant
when the girls dropped out of school
shortly after my story ran it was
devastating
words linger and words matter i learned
and it's not possible to predict the
fallout they can have on a subject's
life it would take me 25 years finally
to earn something nearing nancy's trust
to convince her i wasn't one more candy
peddler intent on exploiting her
relatives for the color of their skin or
purely for my own financial benefit
in 2013 when i hit a snag updating
actually wrote a story uh updated story
on the pregnant teens more than 20 years
after the original explosive first story
it seemed fate that one of them now a 37
year old mother of four lived just
around the corner from nancy's northwest
roanoke ranch house
after some angry relatives tried to
bully me into not running the story
physically threatening me and demanding
a meeting with my newspaper bosses nancy
reassured me you don't need the
permission to do the story just like you
really don't need mine to write your
book not really you don't
and yet months earlier nancy's
permission is exactly what i saw it on
the eve of publishing my first book
about a third generation factory owner
who had battled chinese imports to save
his company i'd given her an advance
reading copy of factory man dog-earing a
chapter on race relations i'd found
particularly hard to navigate it
detailed decades of mistreatment of
black furniture workers and the sexual
harassment of black domestic workers who
often resorted to wearing two girdles at
the same time as a defense against their
boss's groping hands and outright rape
nancy said it's been that way down
through history
a friend of my mom she'd be vacuuming
down the steps on a housekeeping job and
the husband would be feeling her up from
behind my mom had to fill in for her one
day and so she told the man first thing
don't make me open up your chest by
which dot brown meant with the tip of my
knife
nancy and i had come a long way from the
days of sit down and shut up
still it was by no means a gimme when i
called her in november asking for her
blessing to pursue her uncle's story as
a book she was in her mid-60s and
recently retired after closing the goody
shop i wanted her help delving into the
family story as well as connecting with
distant muse relatives including one
albino muse still living in truvon
i'll think about it she said
and the message was clear i was not to
call back she would call me this was
actually november 11th i wrote it in my
calendar thanksgiving came december came
it was almost christmas i sent her a
christmas card with a little note ps
here's my phone number
more than six weeks later oh she enjoyed
making me wait
she finally called
i waited she said so i could give it to
you as a christmas present
it was christmas morning and nancy had
decided to let me write her uncle's
story with her help and blessing but on
one condition she said no matter what
you find out or what your research turns
up you have to remember
in the end they came out on top
i knew the story's ending already i
assured her i'd already interviewed
several people nurses and doctors
neighbors and lawyers all of whom
described the late life care she'd given
them as impeccable extraordinary
i was less certain about who had forced
them into servitude in the first place
about their struggle to have their
humanity acknowledged in their work
compensated how exactly during the harsh
years of jim crow had george and willie
managed to escape
how frustrating was it all those years
knowing that this remarkable story was
so close and yet so far away and did you
ever feel like giving up
um well i did give up because she said
no um she actually said um
i asked her i said you wouldn't you
didn't even let me interview him and say
i would hold the interview until after
um
he passed away because that was her rule
she didn't want anything written about
him until he passed away
she said oh
she said you're too curious
she didn't think i could hold the
interview i said if i said i would with
all the interview i would but she didn't
believe me
um and she now she says oh when you
walked into that shop the first time
and you just thought i would give you
this story i said to myself scratch has
met her match
i was scratching she was the match yep
well you call yourself a unicorn in the
ranks of journalism because in this
globetrotting world you've stayed in one
place roanoke for decades
and how has your staying power allowed
you to write both of your books
both of which required very deep
reporting right
not a lot of books getting writ written
from rural america i mean i live in a
city a valley of about a quarter million
and
most
reporters move on after a few years i
mean some of our best reporters are now
at the new york times they've done great
stuff and i've decided to stay i stayed
at the roanoke times for 25 years i'm no
longer there but um you see i'm still
writing stories that began with my time
at the roanoke times and um
so i'm able to write these stories
because i have time on my side robert
caro says time equals truth
so maybe she didn't want to talk to me
in 1991
she
begrudgingly let me do a restaurant
feature then i started just spending
time there and sometimes i was thinking
yeah maybe she'll let me do the story
but it just became um i have these
places in town i call people in town
that i call my story beacons they're
people who they can lead me to other
people in the community and
at the time in the early 90s in
newspapers across the country diversity
was a big push i mean newspapers were
much better stopped then and i had this
fantastic first editor her name was
wendy zamparelli who was tough as nails
and um the paper was sending a lot of
emphasis on having having more black
editors more black reporters and doing
stories that more accurately reflected
the diversity in our community
and
so that if i was writing a general story
about something
and roanoke has a 23 black population if
one of my four sources in a four-star
story was an african-american she would
send it back and so that was like great
training for a young journalist i'm not
sure papers have the resources to do
that now um but that was wonderful
training and that's what led me to a
beat that the paper called i was the
families beat reporter but really what i
did is um i had been trained to work
outside of my zip code and to be getting
stories
that um
nobody else really had the entrees into
because i had spent time
with emma immigrants refugees caregivers
for the elderly veterans with for with
ptsd and and i had really kind of made
my that my beat and so one of one of my
favorite characters in the book is um he
passed away recently but he's a l
holland he was a muse a distant muse
relative he was a civil rights leader in
roanoke
and he was an 11 year old boy in 1927
when harriet muse got her sons back and
his job after school was he would
he would help a blind man sail sell
brooms on the city market that he made
and so he had this wonderful like kind
of insider view to the story and he was
there when they came home that night and
um so he's 98 when i interviewed him for
this book but i knew him because i had
done numerous articles on it before and
so i just think because i had made those
connections in the community
um
i was able to get people to trust me but
it was really the time the fact that i'm
still there
this is
these are my people i know them and and
they they they trust me
and maybe if she had said yes go ahead
25 years ago you wouldn't have been
ready to write this book you've had
people like joanne poindexter
yes joanne was the newspaper's first
black reporter and so the neighborhood
in roanoke the true vine set and it's
called the west end and the little micro
village within the west end that only
the very old people still call refer to
it as a jordan's alley or jordan's alley
and um joanne was able to uh who's still
she doesn't live in the neighborhood
anymore but she goes to church there and
she was able to put me in touch with
80 and 90
and 100 years old people
who
could help me bring that neighborhood a
lot so one of the questions of the story
is like what happened
um how did she get them back and also
were their lives better in the circus
than they would have been at home which
the begs the question how was life in
jim crow in roanoke virginia um what was
that like was it was it better than life
on the road and so
i was able to drive around with these
older people and i didn't always drive
around but i always got my best stuff
when i drove around it kind of reminds
me like when your kids are teenagers and
they don't want to talk to you except
for in the car right because you're
looking at something else
i mean not
because people when they
not only would like what they were
seeing would jog their memory but i just
think they were more comfortable because
we're both facing forward and it i did i
did that was a technique i used uh
that's not a technique it's nothing
special but i did that a lot in factory
man i would drive different people
around the same places and i would start
to hear some of the same stories but
then the next time i was with them i
could say well so-and-so said this and
then a new story would come out and so
that's my mo i drive around and you also
say with my phone on record with their
permission
you also say that kitchens are a great
place to do another oh yes kitchens well
you all know kitchens right that's where
everybody lands at a party
right you everybody's in the kitchen
even though the house doesn't want you
there because people are just more
comfortable in the kitchens because
that's where we live and so i always ask
if if we can do the interview in the
kitchen i usually have some questions
written out
and
in my recorder
and
it's easier and i also take notes
because i i don't trust the recorder and
it's easier if i have all my stuff on a
table that's what i say but really it's
because i want people to be in their
kitchen because that's where they live
and by staying in one place you haven't
limited yourself in terms of material
because
just
a few blocks away from this another
person wrote another best seller yes
jordan sally yeah rebecca skloots the
immortal life of henrietta lacks
henrietta lacks was born loretta
pleasant
in about a block away from
in jordan's alley about a block away
from where the muse family lived on 10
and a half street so just remarkable
that these i mean i think probably every
place has these remarkable stories but
that these two stories came from this
one tiny place
and um and they're very different
stories they're very very similar but
different yep
yep well the facts in the story that you
wrote are so few and far between that
photographic evidence and research
played an important role yeah and at
what point in the process did you
realize that the photos would be so
vital and how did you use them yeah i
actually there was a circus historian i
was interviewing named dick flint and he
said
he reminded me that the circus managers
would often change their names
the brothers were variously called
darwin's missing links barnum's monkey
men the ambassadors from mars the
sheep-headed men the ecuadorian savages
they were never called george and willie
muse so if i got into a database i could
type in eco and ico but that wouldn't
necessarily bring up all those other
names
and
so i had to be really cognizant of of
that and also
the photographs themselves just became a
great reporting tool because those are
the news clippings were so skewed
against they never recorded what the
brothers actually thought
even the stories about the reunion they
never recorded what the family's point
of view was they even went to the
trouble of quoting harriet musin dialect
but it was really clear from the quote
because it was in the wrong person that
they didn't actually talk to her
but the photographs i i find is just
incontrovertible evidence and so this is
the earliest known photograph of them as
child exhibits and when i saw it i to me
they'd look like scared
young brothers
had been taken from their mother
uh they were told that she was dead and
they should quit crying and um
and i and i just studied it and then
somebody said you know there's
there's a person in charleston named
joshua bond a professor who studies
historical costuming so i emailed him
the picture he blew it up and he saw so
much more in the picture than my
my eyes could see like he noticed he
that the seams were like stretching he
said these suits are about two sizes too
small they're actually kind of nice
suits so it was like there was some care
given to the roots of of these boys
being eastman's monkey men at the time
but you know his ties are skew and the
shorts the the suits are too short um
during this time so you've got that
evidence you can kind of really try to
suss out what's going on that picture
and then you've got family stories of
willy telling everyone that when he was
little he would georgie would look after
him and there was a popular song in 1914
called it's a long way to temporary as a
world war one anthem about missing home
and so you can you can sort of layer the
facts with with interviews and stories
and memories pictures
and um
the documentation as it exists in sort
of this
very racialized lens but if
that that's what i tried to do just to
to bring it into its fullness the
pictures were just great though i found
this picture this is from around 1917
they're with algae barn circus by then
and
so
mr barnes writes a memoir in the 1930s
in which he brags about buying them
and making them a paying proposition so
that's more proof i mean he was proud of
it because why wouldn't he because
everybody
thought
african americans were subhuman and he
was getting something over on them
and um so this picture
um
i showed to nancy when i found it and
it's the first picture of them with
instruments
and
we weren't driving around but that
picture prompted a memory
she remembered willie saying the first
time they were handed pictures it was
just to be a photo prop so one of the
ways that managers would make extra
money is they would have pictures of
their acts
and then they would sell them and they
would keep that money and so
some of the they were called pitch cards
so that was just supposed to be a photo
prop they thought oh certainly they
don't they can't play instruments well
it turns out they were they're kind of
geniuses uh they could hear a song and
play at once by many many accounts
including willie at the end of his life
we have a recording that unfortunately i
can't share but we have we have a
recording of him as a 105 year old
singing it's a long way to temporary and
uh there's a picture in the book of him
playing his guitar and the fretboards
are just totally worn down but he was a
wonderful musician and when nancy saw
that photo she was able to add that
layer of it first being a joke but the
joke was kind of on them because they
were they were wonderful musicians
here's another picture it's the only
known picture of them with one of their
their captors that's algae barnes 1922.
and
once their mother got them back and was
able through a very protracted legal
battle to get them paid
um
you can see in the pictures that
they have more agency in their lives
they're happier so this is like the only
this is a casual backyard picture that's
what they called kind of backstage in
the circus
um and
you know they had friends they played
music there's accounts of and i
interviewed people who remember them
playing music
and uh and the music gave them like this
agency and this power that music does
like any skill that we have any like
writing makes me feel good when it's
working um music made them feel good and
it gave them something to do and it it
gave them
self-power so
and
can you describe what their life was
like
in the circus before their mother got
them and after and explained how many
years went by before right she so i'm
sure that at least 13 years went by it
could have been the the the
documentation is scant on that but um
he said willie always told nancy that um
you know they were guarded kind of
closely in the beginning
there was a bit of stockholm syndrome
going on they were illiterate they were
never allowed to go to school late in
life she taught him how to write his
name even though he was totally blind
and that was a big moment for him he
didn't have to sign an x
um
they
the the sideshow managers
and their main manager was really the
only person he ever said anything bad
about and he really hated him even at
age 107 he remembered him
he remembered some pretty vile things
about him
but um
once she got them back they were and
they knew they could come home after
that
um even though they still try to take
advantage of them and not pay them when
they could get away with it
they became happier and um
and as i say that that was really the
only world they knew
and they traveled the world and they
became famous and they yeah in the
headlines of the new york times
um
they became famous they went to they
performed before royalty in england um
one of willie's whenever the doorbell
was ringing when he was at old when he
was an old man at the house in roanoke
which was able to be bought and paid for
by the time they retired i mean that's
what she did by by getting that legal
settlement
um
whenever the doorbell would ring he
would go housekeeping
which he had learned at a hotel in
london and i just love that
well one of the real heroes of this book
is willie and george's mother harriet
muse can you describe her persistence
and bravery
and how she became what you and others
have
called a badass in her quest to get her
boys back so 1927 roanoke virginia um
very harsh place to be an
african-american um there was actually
city code that said where you could live
and you know you couldn't
you
segregation was
just so ingrained in everything
and so at the circus
blacks were told they had to sit in the
back
under the big top
if it was a carnival they would make one
day
out of the seven day stretch of the day
that african-americans could come but
the circus typically only came for one
day and so in 1927 i think it was
october 14th
it had come to her she told relatives in
a dream that her brothers were that her
sons were with the circus and this is a
story that the family has passed down
over generations so in 1927 the top
law enforcement official in roanoke
virginia
was the founder of the local kkk which
was the largest kkk in the state with a
there's a picture of them in the book
and it was a semi-respectable
institution the best families in town
were members of the kkk i mean just to
give you some context so when the circus
pulls up at 6am
on the train unloads goes over to the
fairgrounds
and that's where they set up the
fairgrounds is where the kkk had the
rallies
so
the sideshow was one of the rare places
in the circus where segregation broke
down because there weren't seats you
walked around like you would go from the
crowd would sort of walk from one part
of the stage to the other as each act
demonstrated their skill or answered
some questions
so
she i have a picture of her from the
next day so i know what she looked like
and then i know how the sideshow worked
and then i have the brothers remembering
they're on stage playing
one of their songs and they can't see
very well because of their albinism
their oscillating eyes
and they see her come up and i've seen
the story
in a in a scene that the family has
passed down and every member of the
family recounts it the same way willie
elbows
george i'm sorry george elbows willian
says there is our dear old mother she is
not dead
and um
so
then the police come eight police
officers according to the newspaper
accounts ringling lawyers
they want to take the brothers to the
next stop which is in lynchburg the
mother wants them to come home they're
her sons the manager actually says
they're my children and they had some
paperwork that had their last names on
uh as his last name
and
somehow she got them she got
the she got she talked the police into
letting her bring them home not going
back to the circus and then not only
that a couple days later she hired a
really young ambitious lawyer and she
filed a lawsuit against the greatest
show on earth i mean
that was moxie
and she kept at it she kept at it
because whenever they could because they
could get away with it they would not
pay them so the manager would switch
them to another show like ringley was
paying him and then he would switch him
to some other show and then he would
pocket the money and then she uh she and
another she found another lawyer and
through this very um
clever but kind of awful sounding legal
arrangement she had them declared
incompetent so that the court was then
in charge if the checks bounced they
would go and find them and they might be
in canada or they might be in oregon
they would actually this lawyer and a
bail bondsman who worked with them would
go find them track them down and get the
circus to pay up
so and then figuring out how they did
that was another little mystery that was
fun to untangle and she was illiterate
and there was no internet and yet yeah
yeah i mean they were being written
about in the headlines of the new york
times
but she didn't know
where they were
and we wouldn't have known enrolling
where they were either because
unless we had a new york times which
it said new york times now in roanoke
it's amazing that she
intersected with them finally it is it
is
well until now the story of george and
willie muse has been largely untold
mainly because of their race and social
status and not to mention their
disability
help us understand this widespread
process of historic erasure and why a
generally racist press not even just in
the south didn't even bother to
interview the family at any point before
during or after their ordeal i
interviewed one of our oldest um
living reporters at the roanoke times
who started working there in the 30s and
he's sharp as can be his name's melbo
melville buster carrico and he
remembered when he started whenever some
an african-american would be in the news
they would have to write comma colored
after their name he remembered the clan
driving past his house with the robes
and hats on in an open-air car
and so that was sort of gave me some
feedback on on what it was like being a
reporter then but in in i i wrote down
some of some of the quotes of the
the way the media treated the reunion in
the roanoke times from the day after she
found their sons
the family reunion was quote was told of
in the newspapers others talked of it
all the while humming happy mammy songs
never quoted the family
they also reported that they were not
over developed in mental capacity which
which i refuted over and over again
through interviews in later years
a new yorker piece profiling them the
following year 1928 said quote they did
there as they walk their eyes didn't
quite focus they loved monkeys and
kangaroos well their eyes didn't focus
because of the albinism another new
yorker piece said they rejoined the
circus that year because quote the fried
chicken had given out in roanoke
there's no mention of the years of
servitude
the lawsuit
no context about poverty in jim crow
because it was just widely believed that
blacks were considered subhuman
in the 1928 season opener of madison
square garden in the new york times the
headline was eco and
ico are happy
the times didn't mention the lawsuit or
the servitude either just that they were
back now and happy because they finally
had the permission of their parents
so
i mean it's just kind of surreal almost
surreal racial thinking
that was
that was the predominant way that people
thought
and it's it's heartbreaking and shocking
but
that's the world i'm trying to
create because that's what they lived in
and that's what that's the
challenges that they faced well here you
thought this was going to be a book
about the circus which it certainly is
and they are endlessly fascinating
stories about the circus but it's so
much about race and here you were
this new york the roanoke times reporter
and the roanoke times hadn't was one of
the many papers that hadn't treated them
well how did you get people to trust you
who had no reason to trust you and what
were some of those stories that they
told you while when you were driving
around well one of the one of the
one of my story beacons was joanne
poindexter the the newspaper's first
black reporter she's now retired and in
her 60s and she called up basically all
the older ladies in her church that had
grown up in that neighborhood and asked
if i would interview them
she's she has helped me so much in my
career when i wrote that pregnant and
proud story that that got me in
so much hot water
after that i had a hard time getting
african-american people to trust me in
the city
i didn't mean to make those girls the
the subject of ridicule i
honestly didn't
but that's what had happened
and um she would actually go out to
interviews like there was um there was a
church that was starting and it had been
a crack house and i was trying to get
the neighbors to open up to me about it
because i wanted to do a story on
like that's a pretty cool story a crack
house turning into a church and joanne
went and sat on the porch of every
neighborhood every neighbor in the
around that and she vouched for me and
so she did the same thing much
years later for me with this too
and um
again it was
uh
they had read my stories they had they
had seen the work i had done since then
where i wasn't just doing like
drive-by anecdote reporting i was really
digging in spending time with people and
so i think i was able to sort of reap
the bounty of just my time there
well one low point in your research you
complained to canadian historian jane
nicholas about the difficulties of your
task and she gave you a valuable piece
of advice saying
if we only wrote the histories of the
people who left detailed records we
would only get to know about the really
privileged people
you have to piece together your evidence
with empathy and conjecture using the
materials at hand how did her words
inspire you well i was just beating
myself up because there were so many
holes still
and um
i thought well that's right you know
nobody the way she put it like that it
it gave me permission
that maybe my story wasn't perfect i
didn't have every single year every
place they were but there was a reason i
didn't have that and that was because of
this institutional racism and the
coverage of it and it just
if i can write about that then i can
cast it into even more deeper context
and that really helped me
um i also complained once to one of
nancy's younger relatives that
it was really hard to get some of these
like basic facts like their their births
weren't recorded
their birth years are listed in numerous
different years in the documents um
the holes again and i was just
complaining to a younger relative it so
she told nancy and nancy sent back the
message
if she thinks this story was hard to
write
she should think about how hard it was
for uncle georgie and uncle willie
to live she better pick her ass up
so
you picked your ass up
i tried i tried well tell us about
george and willie's life after they left
the circus yeah yeah
so because of that secondary lawsuit
where
where their mother got guardianship they
she was able to
the the checks were sent home and they
were most of the money was funneled into
like a retirement count when this was
set up social security didn't even exist
so by the time they retired in 1961
a really nice house was bought and paid
for for them
and the family um
nancy her mother dot um
her grandparents
they they all lived in the house
together and they took astonishing good
care they sort of protected them um
that the barber would come to their
house to cut their hair so they wouldn't
have to go out because people would
still say rude things
and and and they watched over them and
later um when he was in his
late 90s i think it was he was in the
hospital he was actually he was
incredibly healthy he was on no
medications but he had this um it was
they thought it was a balance
obstruction so they put him in the
hospital
um to watch him overnight and some a
nurse put up a heating pad on him and it
was turned up way too high and when
nancy came in the next morning he had
life-threatening burns that took two
years to heal
and
her family calls her the warden by the
way that's her nickname so the warden
was not happy about this
so
she like her great-grandmother before
her
found a really scrappy um formidable
lawyer in town and she sued the hospital
which is the largest employer
in roanoke still
and won a settlement that enabled her
to work and have full-time care for him
and so some of the some of the best
sources of him in his later life are
these nurses who would come to the house
to tend his burned wound and to take
care of him
and he would he and so you could see the
the the
the
how the story progresses from
in the beginning there this cautionary
tale parents would tell their children
when they went out to the circus or fair
you all stay together or you might get
kidnapped like eco and aiko and then by
the end of their life they're sort of
wise elders in in the community given
their nurses
willie giving his nurse um
great advice
he said feed him honey be better than
the person who is mistreating you
and
i just think that's so
i think he had a wonderful late late
life and you describe him as being so
gracious and
he always said god is good to me
even after all he'd been through and
that is on his tombstone it's on his
tombstone yeah he said it like people
say hello he said god is good to me so
she put that on his tombstone and you
said he almost had sort of a magical
quality yeah yes she did she did um
initially i had a little bit of trouble
convincing my publisher my editor that i
was going to be able to find enough
facts to make this a book
and so i was asking i was calling nancy
she had given me permission i said i'm
not sure i'm going to be able to get
this as a book
and so finally
i did some more research i did sort of
an addendum to my proposal on how i was
going to find out all this stuff and
when i finally called and told her that
i had sold the book she said i told you
just remember they always come out on
top in the end so uncle willie
was having this she believed uncle
willie is responsible and she thinks the
book is going to do really well because
uncle willie's looking out for me and i
love that and i hope she's right
well
you
your books are about connecting with
people and about connecting the past and
the present and this is your advice for
young reporters get away from your damn
smartphones and computers
go back to the basics papers scissors
real people be the glue as a great
reporter mary bishop once told you
connecting stranger to stranger if only
for an instant can you elaborate on how
this has just been your your mo
well i mean documents can only take you
so far memoirs written i mean that was a
great find when they found the guy
bragging about buying them all the
paperwork can take you so far but
there's no substitute for um going and
meeting people and hearing their stories
i mean the best parts of the book i
think are this
this these um gritty kind of
microaggressions that these men and
women lived with during jim crow like
the little girls who were walking to
school pastel white lady's house and
there's two parrots on the side porch
and the parents have been trained to
squawk racial epithets at them and this
is what these are the memories they have
these ladies in their mid-80s
rent collectors who accepted sex and
partial payment
um i would have never had these stories
had i not gone out spent the time to get
to know people and them to know me and
to have them open up to stories with
stories and soul of your book well thank
you in addition to the remarkable story
one thing also if you could comment on
was because the brothers were portrayed
in the circus sort of as being imbeciles
can you talk about
willie's intelligence yeah that you yeah
it turns out a friend of mine who's a
lawyer just happened to have deposed him
for that burn lawsuit nick leach
and uh
so i took him out to lunch i was having
trouble getting those
final documents i mean that was quite
like they were misfiled it had the
circuit court clerk had to help me with
that and so i took him out to lunch he
was giving me advice on how i could find
those and he says oh i deposed him once
i said well what was he like
i and he said oh he's lovely he gave me
a little bit of detail and i said did
you think he was mentally incapacitated
he said oh my heavens no another lawyer
who deposed him um
said uh
it was mid-december and he had a better
handle on his christmas shopping than he
did
and he was blind he was blind and he
couldn't get out of the house but he had
arranged for louise to get nancy her
present and knew exactly what nancy was
getting and how much money it was gonna
cost and
uh yeah
the doctors the nurses
he just had this way about him
one of the nurse remembers walking up
the stairs
and
he heard her footsteps
and he said who's there and she said
it's the nurse and he said does the
nurse have a name
you know like you can tell me your name
how hard was it making the leap from
writing articles to books um
well
uh
a good friend of mine that i was a long
long time reporter with ralph barrier jr
had written his first book before
factory man came out and he gave me this
advice which sounds simple but it was
just so on and it gave me the confidence
he said it's just like one very very
very long featured article and so it
really was it's all the same tools it's
all the same recording techniques the
trust building the documents the calling
around to experts
taking what what experts said running by
another expert showing a picture to
somebody who's an expert on costuming
it's all the same skills but it's over
more
more time 100 years both books covered
100 years
and um
and it has to like things have to kind
of
this can't be totally apart from this
part and this part in this part in
factory man um
the my editor said the first time you
read it he said it reads like two books
the first part reads like southern
virginia the second part reads like
china it's about
a southern virginia furniture maker who
took on china a court of international
trade to keep his workers employed
and so what his suggestion was was to
build on what was going on in china
early in the book so at the same time so
it would all seem to be more seamless
and so i had that in my mind as i was
writing true vine so i actually i have
this um this is boring office supply
uh shop talk but i have this stuff
called wizard wall which i have
plastered although it's like a dry erase
and you can move it and it's all over my
walls and so i would keep up with like
little threads that i know i'd want to
keep back to to me that's the big
difference i mean you're still writing
i write like i plot out a chapter
and then i plot out the sections and i
want each section i want each chapter to
read almost like it would stand alone
but
then i want each section to have a
little in journalism we call them
kickers the the end
i want each section also to have a
kicker and then i want the chapter i
have to kick her and i want them
all to sort of then feed on what the
next chapter will be so you're leaving
people wanting to keep turning the page
well this is such an intricate story
there's so many facets and it's past and
present and
how did you figure out that structure
you know you know i like the way you
interweave it you start with the basic
story
and then you you go into you trying to
get the story
so and then and then basically it's
chronological after that except for
these digressions where i'm saying i
can't and then i can't find out next and
so i did this
because um
that adds another layer of context to it
in in newspapers we're really not
allowed to include ourselves in stories
and i always
i mean i always just went along with it
i didn't put myself in the stories but i
have written some essays
and um
i
i feel like it's almost more honest when
we're
peeking behind the curtain a little bit
showing the reader how we got the
information
in factory man some of the best most
telling um
details about john bassett iii are his
constant calling me on the phone
like he's just relentless trying to
control the story and what it is one day
eight o'clock in the morning he's
already called me three times and my
phone was upstairs i was downstairs by
the time i go up at 8 14 he says well i
guess you're sleeping in today
like can you imagine that not being in
the book like that shows like his
relentlessness and so
i would have left some of the best stuff
on the cutting room floor so that's
that's why i do that
well do we have any audience questions
and if you could come up to that
microphone
if anyone has any questions for beth
thank you for being here i've enjoyed
your presentation so much i feel like
you're saying instead of saying sit down
and shut up should say i don't give up
and i feel like we've kind of been with
you through your journey to write this
book and i would just like to know how
you celebrated when you knew that it was
going to publish
when you knew that it was actually going
to become a book what did you do to
celebrate well i called nancy and and i
had a little celebration with her and
then
my husband and i celebrated because hey
i've got an income for the next two
years
and um
this week the book comes out tuesday
we're gonna have a book launch party in
roanoke and nancy and her family are
coming and all those old ladies that i
drove around i hope if they're willing
are coming 102 year old aj reeves from
truvine who brought sort of the world of
sharecropping alive for me in this book
he's going to be
he's uh i said now your niece estelle
said she would come and get you because
truvia's an hour away he goes well if i
feel like coming i'm going to drive
myself oh dear so i'm really i think
it's going to be really fun and exciting
and to me that's going to be the moment
like when when nobody celebrated them
when they came home in 1927 except for
to want to see them and ogle them again
and i feel like i hope it'll be this
kind of special
thing for the family that's almost like
a homecoming you know so that'll be
great that's a great question you
definitely needed a party for this
yeah
thank you
yes ma'am
do i need to go to the mic or can you
hear me i can hear you okay
okay
you know what my phone keeps ringing
this is such an important story and i am
so glad that you never gave up trying to
write it
i'm asked one wondering if
you were african-american would it have
been easier for you to get the
information
or what is your perspective on that yeah
i mean i don't really know because i'm
not um
i
it took me a long time to understand
nancy's mistrust of the media and her
mistrust of me i mean
really i would have held the story if
she had let me interview her but really
not until
i delved into the way the family had
been treated did i really understand
like this tough tough layer that she has
and
um
because i was there she she's read every
single article i've ever written i mean
she was kind of judging me for 25 years
through the stories i wrote
and when i would go in to get my ribs on
fridays we she would talk about whatever
i had written that had been in the paper
we would have a discussion about it and
then she became one of the people she
became one of the story beacons in the
community that would then help me find
other stories and i did a 10-part series
on caregiving for the elderly in
2008 or so and
all the people we profiled in there were
people i got from nancy
so um
i just think it's really important that
we have to be inclusive so back to that
first rule that my old editor taught me
you know you you need to write stories
that reflect all
all of the community and um and it's how
you set up a relationship is that
it is and it's a joy to do i mean there
are days when i drive around and i can't
believe i get paid to do this i
basically get paid it's like getting a
graduate degree in whatever you're
interested in and that's um that's why i
love what i do
thank you so much thank you thank you
beth for thank you wonderful
conversation
wonderful
[Applause]
oh thanks so much
and that was author beth macy live from
the southern festival of books here in
nashville now in about 10 minutes the
next author will be talking about her
book and its national book award
finalist arleigh russell hoax shield and
she looks at the current state of the
political right we'll be back with more
live coverage of the southern festival
in just a few minutes